[Music]
hello everybody
it's time for dear drew digital edition
thank you so much for sending us all
your beautiful letters and gifts we love
opening and reading all of your mail and
we're so excited to showcase more of
your hometown so let's celebrate our zip
code of the day
it's
80231
denver colorado
loves me some denver home to blue
mustang a 9 000 pound 32 foot tall
fiberglass horse sculpture which is
often called
lucifer due to its largely haunting red
eyes the first permanent structure in
denver was not a hospital bank or a
house but a saloon i knew i loved denver
denver colorado we want to hear from you
please send us some mail and now to our
letter
i get so excited to read them
oh oh confetti
dear drew i saw this card at a local
gift shop and thought of you
i i'm obsessed with murray condo the one
and only
marie kondo and her interpreter mikey oh
my god
i've been wanting to send some mail for
a long time you just spark joy
just like marie kondo's organizing tips
to even be mentioned in the condo realm
is enough for me
um you are so beautiful and fun well
gosh thank you love watching your show
thank you what's your favorite marie
kondo tip tiffany denver colorado
i would say that my favorite marie condo
tip
is that
she actually asks you to look at objects
and have
the behavioral emotional question of do
i want this do i need this does this
spark joy obviously
and when it comes to organization i
think marie kondo is really tapping into
you know honestly our behaviors and i
love her show and she's just made me
question things in a way that i had
never thought to
before and i've become
a more organized person because of her
but that organization has led to less
stress and simplification of my life
and
i'm a lot happier so i have to say the
way that marie
makes you
behave and get your life in order is
just as important as her like folding
her underwear and a weird thing i'll
never figure out but
she has made a huge difference in my
life thank you so much tiffany for
associating me with the great marie
condo
and i'm gonna send you a note card back
so
thank you tiffany's
truly yours
[Music]
you